reporter wird ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution so dass sich das
sich lohnt sich sitze weiß dass ich die
natur pectoris oder die zwei wochen
raschelt kalt grau und dem bäcker
speziell und angeschlossener gesunken
mit der rallye startet sie den rand
dieser welt schaffen also dass sie die
hürde zum kontrollieren dass sie alles
danken
also ich brauch halten kündigte minister
posch mini ich hasse zeigen verkracht
selbständiger immer wieder gemacht und
enkel der wiese und schaut hinüber
was machen wir falsch machen
achtung bei roger hofstetter und janine
zobrist träumen von einem
selbstbestimmten leben in einer eigenen
wohnung wegen ihrer kognitiven
beeinträchtigung müssen sie sich ihren
traum hart erarbeiten
dieser film begleitet sie dabei
[Musik]
die behindertenorganisation pro infirmis
betreibt im kanton zürich eine wohn
schule mit zwei standorten
die ausbildung dauert je nach
lernfortschritt zwei bis drei jahre
während der grundausbildung leben die
wohl schülerinnen und schüler gemeinsam
in einer wg
[Musik]
das sind dann sortiert wie sarkozy damit
lernen damit das klappt zum wohnen
es ist ein der ist also sein tisch
umgang mit sich selber und andere dass
man aus so dass man lernt mit anderen
mit uns ist es schwierig am anfang zum
zum lernen also ich finde jetzt als
weitere schwerpunkte der ausbildung sind
die haushaltsführung der umgang mit geld
und die freizeitgestaltung
heute leitet der sozialpädagoge sandro
wie bei den unterricht hier in städten
leben zurzeit vier fonds schülerinnen
und schüler die stube ihrer wg ist
gleichzeitig das unterrichtsthema danke
[Musik]
diesen vorne die politik muss vergehen
dinapoli
ich wollte dass du das mache ich ja
beides
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dann wäre die rosen die wohn
schülerinnen und schüler führen ihren
haushalt gemeinsam
morgen muss schauen ihn zobrist für die
ganze wg das mittagessen kochen
die 25-jährige bespricht mit
sozialpädagogin julia van der kooi die
einkaufsliste erinnern
bevor sie die wohnschule besuchte leute
schauen in zobrist in verschiedenen
sozialpädagogischen einrichtungen
sie hat großen ehrgeiz möglichst bald
selbstständig leben zu können
als
alles nerge
brauchen wir
visual hofstetter hat auch schon in
zobrist eine lernbehinderung sie kann
lesen schreiben rechnen
aber sie braucht dafür etwas mehr zeit
alltägliche tätigkeiten sind für sie oft
herausforderungen die sie schritt für
schritt lernen muss
daran müssen lernen ist das cloud backup
mit einem cut pro jahr schwierig es ist
schon nicht ganz einfach nur mal schnell
nach komponiert von vorn
[Musik]
außerdem zeigen wir herrengasse zum zum
mittelpunkt soll das mit alles
vorbereitet für die ganz wege nun ja das
muss jetzt aus sichtbaren bereich mache
ich mein major im ausbach das gäste-tor
ist bereitet man mit wie viel es zeigt
halte er in rostock zu gast bevor
schulhof städterin die wohnschule
eintrat lebte der 25 jährige bei seiner
mutter nach acht monaten unterricht
braucht der beiden alltäglichen
herausforderungen immer weniger
unterstützung von sozialpädagoge santos
wird das wäre zu einer heißen so
schriftsteller
charakteristisch sind sie auch bekommen
haben liegt das
ich will mal ganz kurz
bis zum 10
ja ich weiß
[Musik]
dazu wäre jetzt geweckt
ich schätze jetzt mal groß bin jetzt
ganz sicher wie ich hatte einen
leiterwagen der frage gesamtheit das
normalmaß und offenthal klare grenze
erwehren kann das jugendwort holen
aber nein
der inder
zusammen
das hat zu holen
[Musik]
das schulgeld von 3600 franken im monat
wird durch die iv und mit
ergänzungsleistungen bezahlt für die
sozialwerke geht die rechnung auf denn
sie sparen langfristig geld wenn sie es
menschen mit einer beeinträchtigung
ermöglichen selbstständig zu leben
[Musik]
die wohn schülerinnen und schüler
arbeiten halbtags auswärts schon in
zobrist hat einen job bei der frank
jacob bäckerei in zürich hier arbeiten
menschen mit einer beeinträchtigung
seite an seite mit gelernten bäcker
ganz wenige ganz wenig angebracht
[Musik]
ist es schwierig sie zum alles lernen
was die damen können oder haben sie das
einfach macht ja so also am anfang ist
halt schon schwierig sie für mich
[Musik]
die bohnen schule macht einen ausflug
nach winterthur
[Musik]
seitdem ist sie nicht
hier hat die pro infirmis eine ein
zimmer wohnung gemietet zum schweigen
wollen ja ja ja ja ja serie freuen sie
sich am meisten
dass ich selber mini hochrhönstraße
[Musik]
schulden auf roberto ich mache
wildfremde person einfach die renova ja
was glauben sie denn dass strom
markus heerdt bad bank könnten sie dann
schon alles so zumal woche alleine wohne
ja so ich bin jetzt so ich bin jetzt
benommen überlegte rezept was so die
einfachste habt wer während für mich zum
zum hochwasser schwierig steht an weil
man ganz alleine und ja schon ja
also putze
nein hier testen die wohn schülerinnen
und schüler nicht nur ihre fähigkeiten
sie probieren auch aus ob ihnen das
alleinleben überhaupt gefällt dschungel
hofstetter hat das probewohnen bereits
hinter sich
mit sozialpädagoge sandro weber zieht
der bilanz
genau wie fühle ich mich in dieser zeit
ist die gefühlt ich habe mich dann
bringt das was willste sei jetzt das ist
viel anstrengender als
kalkar rosé aus kranken prozess steht
vorne machen
was ist passiert allein das schreiben
sie uns warum gesehen doch stress und
brandenburg die die polizei sich nicht
als problem gesehen
im gegenteil durch das gesetz machen
arbeitet als dirigent oder lockt ja du
bist blanik selber gemachte selber
gestalten tricks lässt sich für die sich
wirklich fragen über die ich habe ich
schon bereit wie viele der langsam mit
der onyx usa zwar schon gut gemacht und
ist freut sich dass die ganz gut
gefallen dass das ja dass dir die zeit
einem seo zeigt theaters ist das wohl
nicht selbstständig leben das heißt du
willst eigentlich so ein großes ziel wo
über die wunschschule steigende kurse
gefunden und das ist wie er wollte ich
lieber
nächsten sonntag im zweiten teil dieser
geschichte so hofstätter sucht seine
erste eigene wohnung schon in zobrist
prokop allein wohnen und empfängt
erstmals gäste
[Musik]
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution